[Music]
thank you
I've spent a lot of time on the Smith
breakfast table and for good reason but
does this Smith family really strike you
as the kind of family that gets up at
the same time to have breakfast together
and prepare this kind of spread which
part of any of these non-jerry people is
the part that's like ooh can't miss the
good old family breakfast tradition my
inherent love for cinnamonality and
routine will not be denied also if
you're making a breakfast that has
pancakes toast in what looks like mashed
potatoes with rice sprinkled on top of
it but I'm hoping is grits then you do
not need all these what I'm graciously
going to call hash browns I trust no one
in this room because not a single one of
them is drinking coffee and this isn't
caffeine moderation shaming what's going
on here is a statistical impossibility
to those who rushed out and grabbed the
yasica insta handles all I have to say
is that your commitment to mimicry and
parody of this character has been
underwhelming this sin is on your hands
hi I've placed an auto response chip in
my brain so I can spend time with my
family what kind of lousy auto response
chip responds by declaring it's an auto
response chip a terrible auto response
chip that's what any death crystals from
4pogilon Prime show will never explain
what makes the death crystals from
forbogen Prime better than any other
death crystals and if you're gonna say
they only exist on for bogelin Prime
then we never find out why Rick who
cares about nothing cared about name
dropping this planet dad you hardly put
any syrup on honey stop raising your
father's cholesterol so you can take a
hot funeral selfie but isn't Summer's
logic a bit off here she just said that
the reason funeral selfies are hot is
the grief threatens the cheeks but who's
grieving at Jerry's funeral why are they
called Death crystals do they kill you
you're thinking of bullets Morty while
bullets are technically Crystal and
solids this punch line probably should
have been reserved for jokes about death
metal death crystals show you how you're
gonna die then I hereby Smith they
should be called cause of death crystals
also expirite was right there the
contrived nature of these rocks is
immediately forgiven because of how much
thought went into coming up with and
animating all the amazing possible Morty
deaths in this episode people that spend
their life avoiding death are already
dead and what's dead may never die so
what are people that spend their dead
lives living death Quantum entangled see
I can sci-fi up some random too the idea
of using the expirite is some sort of
morbidity divining Rod is interesting
and all but not buying it even if you
did catch a unified glimpse of your
demise every micro movement would
completely change the possible outcome
in a way that would render it no longer
valid and impossible to recover I
thought you were masturbating
rather I address it it's not so much
that I'd rather you did it's just that
it seems pretty in character for you to
do and nothing has stopped you from
doing it before I'm willing to accept
that you're doing this if you're
title of my sex tape if yours as if the
Smiths collaborated with their next door
neighbor on this fence since it crosses
both yards and I refuse to believe
there's any Universe where next door
neighbors get along well enough to
accomplish this feat operation Phoenix
initially something something cloning
callback something something Rick's
pixelated improv the rest is how I'm
guessing this scene was written but you
are down with fascist dystopias right if
you have to ask your question is
obviously more about dramatic reveals
than your commitment to extremely
problematic political ideologies sitting
on the nasty floor of a school hallway
leaning against the lockers this is your
respite I don't have to be anywhere in
the next few minutes you know where I'm
gonna plop down for conversation
staphylococcus Central that's where
throw that thing in the garbage stop
planning your own death and talk to
whoever you want Rick steals the exact
words I told my younger siblings about
their paper fortune teller oh and if you
don't know what I'm talking about see
also Chatterbox flipper flapper Soul
seller whirlybird Paco Paco or cootie
catcher stop doing meta commentary he
says meta commentary only
being so worried about scientific
accuracy they make space completely
silent when you know your audience would
rather hear the Nazi Morty choking to
death
these shrimple Ricks yelling at Morty
because verbal abuse is fun does your
house look like a tree or no it looks
like this it's like identical to this
actually Rick and Morty hanging Lantern
on a logical inconsistency thinking that
will somehow keep us from sinning it as
if they've never seen one of our videos
before come on just admit you watch TV
sins already
um cliche I'd remove Us in if I could
say for sure that this sign meant no
flossing but I can't so instead I need
to write you up for improper signage bad
at math but I'm giving you an A plus in
confidence Americans wait isn't that the
same student that was sitting on the
floor earlier are you telling me that
wasn't even their locker they were in
front of you sat down and leaned on
someone else's Locker who does that only
if the events of the Pixar movie Coco
are to be believed which I doubt Coco
deniers I certainly have questions about
how or why Holograms eat but the show is
of course touching on that just enough
to pretend like it actually means
something so instead I'll ask how this
holotech is powered and where it's
physically distributed from the show
gets a lot of credit for thinking
through its theoretical Concepts but
when it comes to technology it lives
firmly on yada yada Avenue will you just
show me how to stay alive Morty is now
asking Hollow Rick to help him not die
instead of Consulting the death Stone
even though Hollow Rick helping him not
die was not presented as an option by
the death Pebble show is all over the
place when it comes to how committed
Morty is to following his new
sedimentary God
Precious Dish
nope
first up I think this is a very funny
recurring gag which is something I never
thought I'd say about fascism second the
writers made a teddy bear rig because of
course that's funny but they also made
him mortal in the same way a human would
be mortal instead of giving him soft and
cuddly entrance as we would expect the
commitment to Teddy Rick was less than
that of pickle Rick who was a pickle all
the way through and that's just
unacceptable bringing a chain to a horny
teenager with a death Crystal fight
sure I'm enjoying the every Rick every
more at all at Oneness of it all but how
is he able to so quickly identify which
path leads to Jessica when up until now
he had to take time to zero in on it
Shield me from the law cool two me seeks
callbacks in the same episode but
wouldn't these musics have immediately
shielded him from the law thereby
accomplishing their task and
consequently disappeared
really getting all the sounds correct on
the first or second shot there are 44
different phonetic sounds in English
Morty
44. he loves you little Sparrow he's
innocent case dismissed the U.S justice
system I think we're just about ready to
forgive him and move past this whole
thing he's a free young man and as far
as continuity goes the reset button's
been hit what the [__] did you just try
to tell the audience that none of what
Morty is doing in this episode matters
as it relates to the broader storyline
oh it matters and this is not the last
time you will be hearing about it oh
it's nice to know it's also 2 p.m in
every other universe as well I was
beginning to think this clock was just
broken we eat our prey alive and when we
don't we lay our eggs in their eyeballs
so that our young can Feast on their
brains when they hatch nope nope nope
not looking that up here's the sin for
just making me think about it so what
are these wasp nests for if you
furnished a human type house and why is
there a collectible plate on display if
you don't even use plates in the first
place does no one on this show care
about the important things where's my
boggling there you are don't worry Pop
Pop's back goosing the boglin market
directly after I sold my 1987 slurp for
a measly 30 bucks all that's left of
these Kirkland brand musics
Kirkland shaming it's funny because he
can't be stung but it's also not funny
because he's been spouting off all
episode about being a hologram so we
know that he knows that we know that he
knows that we know that he knows that we
know that he knows them
excuse me
that he's not able to be stung and
that's only because of all the fourth
wall breaking
I have
met for reasons
[Music]
dare I say too fast and only because the
episode is ending soon the runtime
should never dictate the rate of
pupation there's a lesson here and I'm
not the one that's gonna figure it out
is it that Rick and Morty will do just
about anything to make sure they hit
their gratuitous Gore quota am I close
okay fine I'll take the assignment
seriously the lesson is that as Humanity
becomes more and more reliant on
technology to sustain us we're also more
at risk of those same Technologies also
killing us and while it's more likely to
be a dispassionate accident we don't
really know what we're doing in one day
maybe it will be malicious there not
saying I won't do your job for you but
you aren't going to like my consulting
fee I don't want to see any more anime
stuff the comment section when I try to
send my hero Academia somehow makes it
into the episode you ruined the season
four premiere it was already ruined from
the second you decided to take over two
years after season three to bring us any
new Rick and Morty and you know it we're
out of syrup there's clearly some syrup
at the bottom of that bottle might take
some elbow grease but I have faith he'll
get at least a stack of pancakes worth
out of there more importantly though the
bottle's just sitting at the table
without a cap on and there's no cap we
can see on the table where'd that calf
go is the syrup even good anymore now
has been exposed to the elements is
there air you don't know maybe I'll use
my intern gluty gluty arrives from off
screen as if he appeared out of a
[__] portal syrup in hand but how did
he know that Rick was even in need of
syrup I mean maybe Rick staged this so
he could introduce his intern but how
did he know the syrup wasn't going to
run out before it got to him and why
does he even care about introducing the
intern other than to set up an
underwhelming B
plus also the syrup bottle glooty is
using doesn't have a [__] lid on it
either what does his family do with the
lids are they monsters no if you'll
excuse me wait he just dragged his board
and turn into syrup his pancakes and now
he's just going to [__] off feels like
Rick went to the every CEO ever School
of treating interns when Grand prick
pets his belly like that and leaves
without Morty means he's going to go
poop I guess it's that time of day when
we sin that Rick isn't using his portal
gun he doesn't have a problem using it
later in the episode and I don't know
about you but when I realize it's time
to drop the kids off at the pool the
last thing I want between me and the
community center is a car ride honey why
can't you get this excited about your
sat days asking this instead of
wondering why summer knows so many
specifics about her grandfather's
Hershey squirts well I'm man enough to
Simply say I'm going to poop defining
your masculinity by a willingness to
announce your Readiness to sit the
porcelain Throne when you're barely
competent enough to be defined as
sentient assuming that Rick sinks the
Bismarck once a day like a regular human
that is regular right wouldn't this path
be well trodden I suppose this could be
a magically regrowing field slash Meadow
slash macroscopic cilia Farm but I
refuse to keep filling in the narrative
gaps in the show until I get an official
writing credit reverse digestion
extrapolation here's a sin for the
several minutes I spent trying to
imagine slash sketch the anus that would
make the geometry of this pre-owned
nutrient log possible time to meet your
acre nice try but time to meet your
eater would be far more accurate I can't
see how there's any way of knowing ahead
of time that the maker was the eater
also how is the turd pewter only picking
up on the sandwich shouldn't be a
selection of well other two what are you
guys doing did you develop an app but if
gluty already had the app design handy
what exactly did he need Jerry for if
this is his species way of stealing
water from the planet why not just
develop the app immediately what's the
point of all this do you want to develop
an app pomping circumstance rule number
one in app development son never follow
the rules
rule is tattooed on an alien's forehead
dad why do you think Rick would have
that rule Morty would be excellent at TV
sins but the sin here is that Rick
should have known this was a likely
possibility and should have either a
found a serp delivering intern without a
don't develop my deadly app caveat or B
not left said intern with the primordial
smegma film that Evolution deemed
necessary to give the most basic
self-awareness to called Jerry guys
we're getting our first users and it
just happens to be summer because
coincidence thy name is Rick and Morty
this new app just matched me with a guy
that is Sue My Thai
super my type learn to agree Beth wasn't
[__] asking you what you meant summer
so there was no need to explain and how
was the explanation 10 times more
irritating to hear than the thing you
said us okay your Sue Tai works at
Jersey Mike's and sees 25 fish shows a
year then Danny must be independently
wealthy because tickets along with all
the drugs you would have to purchase for
25 fish shows aren't cheap this world
cares too much about bands and too
little about love and I Think I Love You
Tommy as the beeping Tommy has the
Peeping Tommy Tommy Tommy Tommy Tommy
just hitting the fact that any menu
claiming to have the best frog food
would advertise this basic ass sandwich
and not its fleice cream cheeseburger or
Aunt Jovi Pizza
he knows where I live He's Crazy you
have 470
000 messages we're just left to imagine
how Rick was able to find and leave
voicemails with 470 000 flies and just
accept that it happened even if he
managed to automate some of the
voicemails how is this his best option
if he's not afraid of murdering child
flies why is the far more convenient
decision to torture this adult fly not
top of the list
you idiot I have 800
000 kids thinking the amount of children
one has coincides with how many they're
willing to let die I mean it totally
does but we're not supposed to announce
that to the world I'm not arguing that
being hit by a car isn't an effective
form of contraception but it sure does
feel like dealing with the Splinter and
a finger by removing the entire arm had
you bothered Thomas to love you would
have learned by now it is as abundant as
water you know what isn't water so we'll
be taking yours oxymoronic expositioning
aside X poxy [__] initiating we've got
an aliens come to Earth to steal our
resources cliche boy scoping for this
[__]
my wife's still alive she she went into
remission 10 years ago what did you do
today oh I uh pooped on a really awesome
toilet I found wait a [__] minute
let's talk about the villain's plan here
Rick just found and traveled to an
alternate universe to find a Tony who
used his toilet despite his wife still
being alive and then dragged him in
front of this universe of Stoney to
prove he's lying putting aside the fact
that he found the perfect Tony in a
matter of seconds what the [__] does
that even prove unless Rick can say that
every Tony in every Universe makes this
Choice regardless of circumstances this
doesn't prove [__] so next time you
stumble onto a toilet that feels too
good for your ass trust me it is but how
did Tony even find the damn thing in the
first place and why didn't Rick have any
sort of defense or Shield or [__]
laser beam that turns you inside out and
teleports you into the final days of a
civilization that Prides itself on
flaying any and all visitors with a
lime-soaked cheese grater before they
fall into the abyss of a black hole I
think he'd get a kick out of that
foreign
I suppose we can add allowing your anus
to give the finger to an alien to the
list of defecated fours after you left I
thought about what you said and how much
I needed it skip you
how you're supposed to poop either that
or God knows something about pooping we
don't regardless I'm torn grossed out
and very confused come poop with me poop
with me Tony aren't you gonna join us in
the pooping Tony how's the pooping Donny
how's the pooping
tiny tiny you can make a perfectly
realized toilet-filled simulation of
heaven but you can't share a toilet Tony
would be the king of his own Throne at
TV sins I get that this drawing is
likely gibberish chiefly because Jerry
drew it but at some point I have to
wonder how even his lonely brain cell
doesn't realize the futility of its
actions like why spend the time drawing
a portal gun you don't possess a grandpa
that isn't here or a baseball bat you
don't have come on adventures of Jerry
and Morty okay foreign
to the oxygeny breeze and didn't even
deserve this pity five vibration
I'm assuming you chose this [__]
thing as your method of locomotion so
what the [__] were you expecting here
where's your daughter hey you're right
she join Isis we've got Isis jokes y'all
that's what I thought gluty looks like
you and I
are all we got well this worked out
conveniently enough for Jerry that I'm
awarding it 10 cents then those 10 cents
will be awarded their 10 cent matches
which they will then cheat on each other
with the other 10 sins you know what
just add the damn sins already
[__] that's my name don't wear
it out is it though I mean it's not
beyond the realm of what the show is
capable of but that feels more like a
season six style of episode considering
the presence of Sam Neal Jeffrey Wright
and Taiko YTD I'm genuinely shocked that
this scene does not contain a Ted Danson
also look I'm not one for promoting
infidelity but if Ted Danson wants you
to cheat on your husband then you cheat
on your husband that is Ted dancing
people this episode is 37 defecation and
honestly I'm pooped out enjoy using it
all by yourself while you sit there and
think about how nobody wants to be
around you however only Rick and Morty
could turn the active decorating
porcelain into a beautiful metaphor
about how hoarding precious things is
not as fulfilling as we believe in the
true Joys and the sharing of said things
with the people you love and for
bringing that home by making Rick's
suffer through his own booby trap I
shall happily allow the sin counter to
drop a deuce
Cliff you
can spider's still alien from Morty's
point of view it'd be pretty confusing
you've already found an earth spider on
this mountain so specifying its alien
origin feels pretty warranted everyone
knows the pet entry is more fun when
it's safe for the really important stuff
like critiquing self-aware cartoons on
the internet also this episode opens
with a pretty clear Star Trek 5 the one
with God reference which has led us to
using the side-by-side comparison to
prove it which has led to all of us
watching more Star Trek 5 the one with
God than we ever need to which has
rather fittingly led to sin
will I be sending this scene because it
uses the phrase anti-boobie even though
I know for a fact it's talking about
booby traps and not actual boobies yeah
yeah look we all like saying booby but
someone has to nip these inaccuracies in
the bud also great idea but what if this
place contained traps that didn't rely
on projectiles with these suits have
been useful against disappearing Bridges
quicksand or those irritating statues
where one always speaks the truth and
the other one always lies more like
trying to hard con or more like trying
too hard to come up with an insult for
the heist Khan that is trying too hard
Khan or something Khan yes sir fans
Morty which we are not guests don't have
to be fans in fact there are plenty of
people out there who attend things or
watch movies they know they'll hate so
they can give themselves something to
complain about which honestly fits Rick
to a [__] tea I'm not one to judge
based on physical appearance but the
fact that this individual's eye is not
fully connected to their body is giving
me all of the heebie-jeebies and I would
like it to stop please thanks for doing
this guys what's the job that was it bye
I would say I feel bad for glar Angie
flint and Dracula but they chose to show
up at the location without even knowing
what the job was so that's kind of on
them it's showtime Morty and I don't
mean a bad impression of HBO
Yellowjackets Twin Peaks the return turn
in the first six seasons of Dexter would
like to have a word with you lab coat
rip off doctors
fully developed a sentient lab coat then
I guess he's kind of ripping off doctor
strange but also Rick developed a
sentient lab coat why isn't he using
that more often your booze mean nothing
I've seen
reason I'm able to read YouTube comments
somehow makes its way into the script
make the far the worst one I'm just
gonna go ahead and send myself for
liking Ocean's 12. I have no good
excuses I just love watching people
enjoy European Vacation gonna go ahead
and give myself a sin for liking
National Lampoon's European Vacation as
well oink oink my good man
at least eight or just three of
Sanchez's five that's not how math Works
Morty well no Heist is complete without
a double cross okay maybe nightly
predicted Rick would take the bait at
the tomb which would result in the
highest off but how could he even known
Rick's team would be so willing to
portray Rick especially when Rick has a
reputation for murder
What the hi what the sh what are you
doing here I'm you but from several
minutes in the future look this episode
gets Mighty and confusing If You Don't
Know How It Ends so I'm here to set you
straight when needed makes sense but
what's with the weirdly deep announcery
voice don't worry that'll make sense
later the important thing is that these
three were specially selected by Rick
because he knew they'd betray him so I
guess just do the thing where we stay in
the show for the time we wasted writing
a sin that it later disproves see ya
okay uh yeah what he slash I said and I
had the perfect job heisting the Crystal
Skull he got the skull already looks
like Rick and Morty left their crew and
went straight to see nightly on stage so
how did nightly have enough time to
recruit Rick's heisters set the heist in
motion and
again already sorry buddy we're about to
see there's a huge time gap between Rick
and Morty leaving the crew and then them
turning up a nightly show and that's
when all the heisting happens we're
better offsetting that there's no way
nightly could have known Rick was going
to dick around for a few hours before
coming to see him which is the only way
nightly had enough time to pull off the
heist okay thank you but wouldn't it be
better to just lay all this out now and
save some time
looks like you're available for a job
Rick and Morty literally just laughed
could nightly not have waited until they
were leased out of earshot okay let's
take a second to talk through this Heist
glar steals some keys and hands them off
the key catcher who hands them off the
double microwave who well microwaves
them as a distraction to presumably
clear out security they couldn't have
microwaved anything metal why did they
have to go through the effort of
stealing the specific set of keys
[Music]
shifter just shapeshift in front of the
damn camera I don't care if the crew is
in charge of the surveillance room now
that's still recorded footage of their
actual identity why even risk it knew
that shirt off screen we're smart we'll
figure it out also they turn into the
security guard give the thumbs up and
the next thing that happens is that
monitor Lord switches off the lasers
allowing Angie to steal the skull why
the [__] does the crew need a security
guard at this point
I'm trying to figure out how miles
didn't know by the weight of the attache
that there wasn't a crystal skull in it
I'm not saying he should have known it
was a recent Deuce Rick dropped but the
stench alone should have given something
away God damn it Morty what did I tell
you you gave him a time limit that he
needed to pay attention to but this is
also the kid that said top of nightly's
eight or just three of Sanchez's five so
I'm pretty sure you should have been the
one checking the clock Rick write an
algorithm based on two heist movies I
slept through and use it to automate a
joyless process you call Art Rick
clearly has an issue with the heist
genre being overly formulaic and
predictable but sometimes it's that very
predictability that brings people to
comfort and joy they need from their
movie watching experience we don't all
have to like the same stuff and we don't
all have to agree except for Army of the
Dead [__] that movie somehow no one in
this long line catches on to what's
happening until all of them get
hypnotized look Morty I did not know
that that was gonna happen that's not on
me that's not how homicide law works
complete
told you Morty
he's still got it oh come on the entire
universe is in danger and yet Rick took
the time to recruit all of these
students to set up this attack just to
prove that Professor poopy butthole has
damn it what now hey I'm with you on
this one but they're gonna make the same
point in the post-credits scene and
steal our thunder so I think we'd better
send them for leaning on callbacks to
characters no one likes but I like Mr
Poopy butthole no you don't
are you ventriloquiver
in this episode alone we've seen Rick
block a hammer with a sudden robot arm
but a [__] Arrow hits the mark how
I'm sure it's not the show sacrificing
its Integrity just to show us a unique
superpower Rick Sanchez I presume damn
it guys Elon Tusk listen we need your
help Rick Morty why me Elon Musk
oh look what could possibly be wrong
here this thing is quite good hello
there steady on no objections here at
all I just wanted to come back and send
this one again oh cool
at this point heistatron has become
large enough to Heist entire planets but
is it even heisting anymore everyone on
this planet knows that they're being
heisted are we supposed to believe that
there's no way to scale up a heist to a
planetary level that doesn't just
involve making all the gadgets bigger at
this point it isn't heisting it's just
breaking and entering with a sprinkling
of genocide instead of two heist movies
I slept through randotron's algorithm is
derived from the plots of three David
Lynch movies I pretended to like to make
my friends shut up for me the crucial
question here is which three David Lynch
movies I think it's only fair that we're
told where on the spectrum between Dune
and blue velvet this is going to be so
we know the best way to pretend we've
seen either one if our Collective
behavior is just random enough we should
be able to walk through heistatrons
lazily contrived [__] like it's not
even there but even choosing to be
random is a plan if the end goal is to
out Heist heistotron relying on
Randomness will either be so random that
you never get to the desired outcome or
not be random enough to not be predicted
by heistotron I don't like these little
Jabs you get in Elon signed literally
all of Twitter surprisingly my issue
here isn't the consumption of diapers
but the fact that this box specifies
fresh suggests there is a not-fresh
diaper alternative on sale the most
unbelievable part of this episode is
that Morty's room would be this clean
I've got something to tell you let me
guess when you invented me and randotron
you swapped our brains if he knew
heistatron was going to go Rogue why
does he even need randotron why couldn't
he would just program to Fail-Safe into
Heist
here we go again buddy believe me I am
with you but the next five minutes are
going to get super [__] weird and I'm
still not certain how many switchers
actually make sense and honestly I'm not
sure the show does either let's set it
for Rick labeling these brains and then
immediately switching the labels just
for the purposes of the flashback that
heister Tron can't see to compensate for
a Switcheroo Rick couldn't possibly have
predicted
oh what well if the brain inside of you
is actually heistotrons it matters
because it explodes when it hits six
levels of contrivance I mean could he
not have made it four and saved us all
some time in migraines well done Rick
randotron I'm afraid not but if Rick
built both machines how the [__] did it
manage to switch out its own motherboard
and why did it need to bother with this
earlier Switcheroo also if this is
heistotron that means this was randotron
which means it shouldn't have blown up
after that sixth contrivance because I
programmed you to believe that I
programmed you to believe that robot
kids what's happening Professor poopy
butthole he's learning I think it's fair
to say that nothing within this rambling
incoherence could be considered learning
in fact I would argue that we're all
dumber for having experienced it Ricky
Mortensen should be awarded no points
and may God have mercy on our souls it
appears the only perfect Heist is one
that was never written goodbye Rick and
Morty writers create a paradox they have
no idea how to solve so they blow it up
deny its existence or banish it to an
alternate reality cliche
you know that screenplay that I've been
writing Netflix is pretty interesting
morning Morty I'm so excited for you
wait is Rick being sincere right now
about a Netflix deal what is
okay last one I promise we're about to
find out that Rick with his Adventure
into motion just to disillusion Morty
and make him sour to his own high script
however I think we're safe to send him
for the many many many millions of
people that had to die just so that Rick
could crush his grandson's passion for a
project oof that's messed up even for
Rick right see you at the sin removal
wait the what now well let's hear about
this Heist movie okay so it's kind of
all built around this big crew with like
a cool double cross and then this big
awesome twist expecting us to believe
that Netflix didn't green light this at
okay and then cancel it by awesome twist
if Morty ever gives up on a single dream
it better be because of his own
disillusionment somehow Rick and Morty
manages to pull off sitting everything
Trophy and cliche about heist movies
while also inceptioning itself into an
excellent homage of an example of how to
do the genre in a unique and satisfying
way oh and on that sin removal I guess
it's time to head back and make sure
past me doesn't make a bigger ass of
myself than usual I still don't
understand the deep voice thing but
better safe than paradox am I right I
got a date with density
[Music]
it's not knowing that even with the
Sleek design and increasingly fallady
these space blasters will never be able
to strike both fear and love into our
hearts like the original Super Soaker
you Rick we get it you don't care about
anyone or anything and I don't care
about you not caring about anyone or
anything the person viewing this video
doesn't care about me not caring about
you not caring about
Lord anyone or anything Justice for
Chachi did you get the ultimate cube is
anyone else thinking about Cube squared
hypercube it has nothing to do with this
episode but neither does this McGuffin I
mean Cube also now I'm just upset we
never got cube cubed ultimate Cube
because someone decided Cube zero was a
better idea
cubes I mean prequels I want my dragon I
want my dragon I want my dragon kids the
convenient trajectory of this out of
control fall to planet Earth where they
Land close enough to be discovered and
taken to a hospital that somehow knows
to contact their family without anyone
questioning the whole space travel part
or Rick and Morty survived this and you
choose your ship crashed in Malta Beth
points out that Rick's ship entered
Earth's orbit and crashed onto an
archipelago in the central Mediterranean
Sea between Sicily and the North African
Coast known for historic sites related
to a succession of rulers including the
Romans Moors French British and the
Knights of Saint John like that's the
weirdest thing about this situation
I'm okay says the man whose body is in a
cast but more concerningly whose fingers
are outstretched and unbending at the
joints Rick just regained Consciousness
in his hanging bag of water isn't
connected to anything if I've learned
one thing from medical dramas it's that
unconscious people always have a straw
going from the hanging bag of water to
their arm I'm not cold bleeding my
sister trying to argue her way out of
menstrual synchrony at summer camp
somehow makes its way into this episode
also no one in the neighborhood ever
sees any of these things ever my name is
Baltimore breaker of Sky Slayer of
mountain if you have to announce that
you're slaying it you're probably not
slaying it and unless dragons are the
main contributor to climate change then
I'm gonna say that balthramaw has broken
more wind than Sky I'm guessing you'd
rather not be tagged in this is is she
talking to the dragon from another
dimension right now does she think he
would be linked on social media or even
know what that is I want you to take us
to the airport and get us two
first-class tickets to Florida cats
thinking they can just show up in
Florida whenever they're looking for a
good time like it's their own personal
playground as far as States go it
deserves a little more courtesy than
Ohio I want to enter my Lair and sleep
upon my horde until the age of man
expires Mondays what's this show called
ass they solve ass crimes this ass is a
clue go to her ass go to Brenner ass I
love you ass should I pause ass show
passes ass for all the gluteus amounts
of some butt
and that's the end of the Morty gets a
Dragon episode it is not I hoard that
which all kind covet but not everyone
covets this specific drink so the dragon
could essentially collect any random
thing simply because some people like it
also why would the Ecto Cooler drink be
considered something to covet when it
was in production for so long it's not
like it was rare it was produced for
years small soldier spin pops Rick loves
pop culture things from the past to make
him more relatable cliche hey why do you
have Futures self-titled album on vinyl
Rick loves pop culture things from the
present to make him more relatable
cliche he signed it in Molly and
Percocet hey make sure I can only
imagine is something akin to oil pastels
we all know that would never really dry
these beach umbrellas that are not
anchored and when absolutely be blown
around the beach flip up with the wind
and knock an unfortunate passer by
unconscious not that I have any
experience minding my own business on a
Sandy stroll only to be woken up minutes
later by a half naked sunburned man
chuckling about probabilities what I and
who it was him
right but she also asked why someone
should in the sand so is everyone gonna
just ignore that what if his reason was
so profound that everyone decided to
join in and bury their shirt on the
beach what does it mean when's your lame
Morty just summoned a Taylor Swift
concert likely a live one in summer
thinks that's lame that's a free concert
forcing a cage animal to free its mind
with drugs and yes I'm assuming the
drugs are mind expanding in some way but
even if they aren't wife with a creature
that is [__] with enough as it is
bonding why does it feel better now oh I
hope it's not because you're watching
but don't go anywhere here's the thing
that Rick says to his grandkids in this
episode your dragon soul
my grandpa
grandpa I am so sorry that is a total
violation how would Morty know that the
Dragon Gin Soul Bond with more than one
person at a time why wouldn't the wizard
know that a dragon can Soul Bond without
warning see people this is what happens
when no one reads the fine print of the
blood bonding contracts that we agreed
to without a thought Grandpa do
something or I will tweet and you will
be canceled show treats this as a
credible threat without giving us the
slightest idea of how you cancel a Rick
and even if it were possible to cancel
your rescription we all know he would
just [__] off to some new dimension
where he hasn't been canceled yet it
takes like 78 years to hang a dragon
what an odd thing for Morty to know I
assume he knows the length of time it
would take the hang of dragon because of
the book He's reading so I could also
say what an odd fact to have inside the
Tome of dragon spells in lore make it
looks like it's coming out of your
butthole me is a thing that Rick just
said to his granddaughter in this
episode yeah yeah despite this agreement
it does not look like the hero came out
of her butthole and any attempt to
achieve this seems to have been
primarily done by the camera operator
and not summer power of 12 feet
laughs
[Laughter]
I never thought I would laugh so hard at
the simple visual gag of Rick getting
his ass kick
and there's wizard porn in the
background
oh Ricky Morty you you take my breath
away and if the goal is to make
something up why not make up something
funnier that cat would have a point if
it listened to the remainder of the
Brodus explanation of what a peanut
butter gargoyle actually is it could
have been hilarious and for that reason
alone I'm angry that the cat interrupted
I guess I'll never fully understand this
totally made a hilarious sex position
its correlation to statues and mashed
peanuts stupid cat oh why can't couples
that start out cheating ever end up
happy did Rick know he was cheating
they're not a fun seem to explode into
accidental bonding and non-intentional
cheating and sure Rick would have
cheated anyway and we all know it but
this didn't seem to be that sort of
situation they were both surprised by it
how about finding the spell that unbinds
me from your [__] Dragon no spells
can do that only the wizard can unbind
Soul bombs yes in the primary tools of
wizards or spells but instead of arguing
that I'll just say that two minutes
later they all agree that killing the
wizard can break the bond so either way
this statement is untrue we like it down
here because we could woolly mammoths
get out before watching this episode I
never really thought about woolly
mammoth erotica but knew it wasn't a
thing and now thanks to the writers and
the internet I have confirmation that it
is in fact a thing so this sentence for
Humanity's boundless creativity and the
fact that we found ways to use it that
can simultaneously Inspire wonder and
evoke fear it's high time I emerge for
my [__] of gold puberty so killing the
wizard will break my Soul Bond yes it
solves all of our problems interest to
get on with the dragon show glosses over
all the important questions related to
this resolution like how or [__] why
why wouldn't he Morty didn't agree to
this experience at all he was actively
looking for a way out of it without
having to Soul Bond with nine other
beings he should talk to someone about
this violation of his person an entirely
too early exposure to the pleasures of
inner species bonding wait why did the
dragon come because you so [__] him
and have a soul orgy with your sister
and Grandpa and every Dragon we could
find yeah is a thing Cindy do I really
have to complete this one or do you get
the point
cool thanks no look I just want to be
clean I I feel dirty after everything
that's happened how about a quick hand
bond this moment of pressuring a kid
into any number of sexual Soul bonding
scenarios goes on for all of these
should be jailed amounts of some time
I'm from outer space happy no exactly
because no answer would be satisfying
writers use this cat as a proxy in their
attempt to Gaslight me into thinking my
need for answers is what has left me
unsatisfied by this episode and not the
boner killing Dragon zest get out get
out
I'm not sure why Rick doesn't just kill
this cat for whatever it did he just
went through and murdered all the
Wizards guards even the ones that were
just reading a book why did the writers
draw the line at murdering a horrific
alien cat creature that causes Rick to
consider suicide it's for the
post-credits scene isn't it
[Music]
we are the [__] dragons [__] caves but
dragons we [__] up there all dragons
are [__] enough [__] fresh wet [__]
ten [__] Soul orgy the all [__] [__]
Phoenix dragons
Morty be sure to pee before we go this
adventure is going to be a long haul and
I don't feel like emptying The Jug while
the pee will return momentarily it in
The Jug are ultimately red herrings that
exist only to set up a rather unfunny
centipede who eats urine joke later so
you're getting two scenes Rick and Morty
for pissing all over my valuable time
the major Atomic Matrix slightly lighter
than air and now your shoe shoes are
heavier than air which makes you
neutrally buoyant which I find
personally more impressive conceptually
than walking on water but what do I know
I wasn't born into the god business I
guess Rick's proclamations on his
godliness make this decision and the
resulting hijinks the product of his
hubris but that won't stop me from
pointing out that Rick's magic does
whatever the plot needs pistol probably
could and should have been able to make
Jerry neutrally buoyant without his
shoes but you think the centipede wants
to eat your pee since matter can be
neither created nor destroyed I have to
ask where does the pee go when it's
inside the centipede I mean even if it
evaporated or something that still seems
Less Pleasant than just peeing in The
Jug you've written out of the story for
some reason you young people think space
is like Saturday Night Live you see it
every day so you dream of being in it so
then it's nothing like Saturday Night
Live because it's not on every day and
I'm pretty sure whichever generation is
currently being accused of lacking work
ethic has never seen it literally
everything is out here and unlike
everywhere else I'm too busy to help you
never mind the fact that he does end up
helping Morty after he gets bitten by
the space snake I'm more concerned that
the writers think changing a space Tire
requires more concentration than
toppling a Galactic Federation seducing
a hive mind or fixing a fragmented
space-time which you coincidentally also
broke Morty's starting to look like a
90s Japanese ghost I'm not gonna say
Rick trying to flex his knowledge of
ringu but I'm more than willing to call
him out for not knowing that Juan The
Grudge came out in the odds imagine
being a racist snake hey other snake I
hate you because you're the wrong color
snake I had a hearty laugh when I
realized how easy it is to replace the
word snake in this statement with the
word human then I cried because frankly
it's sad that a lot of humans have yet
to learn such a simple lesson but then I
laughed again because conceptually a
racist snake is just funny then I cried
again because conceptually a racist
human is not funny so take your sin back
so we can get back to laughing but also
this snake parade is traveling in a
straight line spitting right in the face
of the slithering snake aesthetic that
has abandoned aerodynamic efficiency for
the sake of these wobbly snake Rockets I
I can't be the reason why 19 billion
snakes lost all hope using Morty's guilt
is a reason for him to do some
questionable things with a snake sure is
a weird way to get the story rolling
especially when you consider how many
people he killed in episode 1 of this
season and how little he cared about the
hope he robbed from those families I
don't know which Red soda this is but
without naming names I drank one of them
several years ago after walking five
miles in the hot Texas sun and then
proceeded to vomit furiously never been
able to forget the uniquely potent
flavors of its Ingress in subsequent
egress and the site of red fluids has
continued to haunt my Waking Life so as
far as I'm concerned they're all a sin
Morty is suddenly not being smart enough
to know that when this snake sheds the
temporary tattoos will likely go with it
is slightly less concerning than the
overt speciesism he displays by thinking
one snake could be so easily replaced
with another I'd be like me showing up
at your Thanksgiving dinner with a
matching Team Edward tattoo and acting
like I didn't regret getting it your
family would see right through it every
writers think they can milk this plumbus
every time they need a quick laugh
this snake is somehow now wearing the
space snake suit properly even though
earlier Morty was shoving it into the
suit face first if it doesn't work for
sleeping bags it shouldn't work for this
the next two minutes of this show will
be Super Cuts of snakes doing the same
things humans do with these same things
humans would use to do them because it's
funny to anthropomorphize animals
especially when it makes no sense
evolutionarily but unfortunately the
funniness of the SS
doesn't negate the sininess of the logic
[Music]
to be fair newscasts involving humans
are no more interesting than this
downbeat how do you in this [__] game
we've never gotten that far Rick
spending time with his grandkids in a
scenario that doesn't involve putting
their lives at risk makes me question
everything about this scene like is this
a simulation I mean are they a
simulation not am I a simulation I am
100 certain that I am real sure you
pause Beth with a device Christopher
Walken gave me after a record session
taking the long way around saying remote
just so you can make a reference to an
Adam Sandler vehicle from the mid-2000s
thinking this is a better name for a bar
than Devil's protuberance of the mammary
gland upon which the lactiferous Ducks
open and milk is drawn just rolls off
the tongue right one Diet Sprite remix
please and uh is anyone here an Uber
driver Jerry the obvious pool table
light not being over the actual pool
table and frankly your bar has a lot of
sailing things Jerry brings up an
interesting point here that honestly
isn't addressed enough in this world
when you over ceiling fan your bar
you're just asking for trouble whether
it's a man who brings in a boulder one
day because he claims he will float
without it or it's Davey having one too
many shots at Tito's and then deciding
to see how many pool cool cues you can
jam in all the fans bad things will
happen things you'll never be able to
unsee just say no to over ceiling
Fanning you will thank us summer house
suits shook in my by your playlisting
fleekness tonight trainers thought my
cheeky ass would be high key stressed by
the vibe but summer Squad is just being
extra and that's super sus so bye
Felicia I think my little brother got
bit by a snake in outer space and killed
it with a hubcap can you alter the
course of a species Evolution like that
without repercussion saying the more he
altered the course makes it sound like
there was a predetermined destination
when what happened was more akin to an
unintentional participation in their
evolution I'd say an encounter with a
new species that results in death is
very much in line with the principles of
natural selection in this case the snake
literally bit off more than it could
chew and as a result they were not
selected for the next round of the
tournament get behind me I will protect
Beth was right there watching the creepy
snake man's Judgment Day sales pitch
aliens I am a robot sent back in time by
the snake resistance to protect you from
serpicor so her reaction here is more
comedic than logic dick Rick pulp
fictioning Morty back to life in the
middle of Crossfire from time traveling
snakes seems much harder than helping
Morty deal with one snake while changing
a tire but for reasons Rick seems much
less angered here than he was during the
cold open the war between snakes and
machines snakeration 2 Judgment snake
how exactly were they able to get a
picture of Morty even if the snake was
able to describe how he looked this
attention to detail is insane I know
we've gone over this so many times but
you can't just write the present and
expect us to know what that means does
that mean 2019 present because that's
not the [__] present for me get
behind me your brood will seat all life
on this planet that doesn't make sense I
don't care if it doesn't make any sense
the deceitful way that Morty brought
this earth snake to snake earth makes
the seeding of a planet more problematic
than the weird sacrifice at the
beginning of Prometheus I can't get
reception at my dentist but Jerry can
make a phone call thousands of feet in
the air Cherry almost never hits his
Target outside of the bedroom so this
working is just as much [__] as
Jerry not being immediately killed by
the end impact also the depth of this
pocket and this phone not falling out of
it I don't suppose you guys will take a
bribe attempting to bribe a snake
officer of the law
anyone else want legs the results of
this literal and drastic intervention in
the biology of snake kind don't play a
bigger role in the snake evolution of
this episode it's just 1985 but with
snakes you know kind of like 1952 with
meerkats but not so much like 1976 with
possums that one was a disaster also
show wants me to believe that
Massachusetts is a phase that all
pre-warp civilizations must go through
that book has everything they need to
create snake time travel and they're
getting it in 1985 snake time the
existence of this book tells me that the
writers are aware that I'm aware that
they're aware that I'm aware
what was that
Oh [__] forgot I left narrator bot
running how long did I leave this thing
on wow he should have been watching a
lot of Rick and Morty looks like he was
right in the middle of sinning I guess I
shouldn't leave this episode unfinished
well let me see where he's okay what was
he trying when he was sitting here look
I don't know I don't know what he was
doing here I'm just gonna go with
something about some convenient 1980s
time travel [__] cliche snake or ham
Lincoln survives this not that I wanted
stageram Lincoln to not survive this but
why is snake Lincoln so ready to accept
time travel that immediately reads this
note instead of being more concerned
about what just happened to the
well-dressed man from the 80s snake
Hitler not using a shower curtain but
mostly just being a snake Hitler just
have to keep my grip Jerry says as he's
holding on to the outside of a plane
likely traveling at something around 600
miles per hour craters if you're gonna
do this kind of we're eventually going
to need a Jerry is an immortal super
being episode to explain it if that ever
happens we promise we'll give this sin
back
since British Airways once flew a 747
from LA to the UK on three engines now
I'm gonna say that Jerry causing what I
imagine be the first ever snake Strike
should have been a cause for concern yes
but not nearly the catastrophic event
that the show wants me to believe it was
also no matter how many times I watch
this I continue to see a rocket-powered
alligator that suffered the loss of two
legs and not a rocket-powered snake that
has suffered the growth of two arms it's
pandemonium out there Morty being a
snake demonius his soul somehow during
all this hacking and slashing Summer's
clothes stay clean how is the blood
physics of this scene just as silly as
Kill Bill but in the opposite direction
chokes me without consent summer would
be 50 Shades of great at TV sins also
that's about as much curvature as you're
going to get from a time travel story
Josh futterman has entered the chat I
have fun snowing those snake costumes
together you little [__] wait did Morty
say snowing instead of sewing so you run
that one back again I have fun snowing
okay one more time a little bit slower
Christmas episodes
that book has everything they need to
create snake time travel and and they're
getting it in 1985 snake time the
existence of this book tells me that the
writers are aware that I'm aware that
they're aware that I'm aware
yes in this video I revealed that I
built a robot to do the sitting for
shows I'd rather Skip and this silly
attempt at retconning my powers in the
cineverse was definitely a one-off gag
that will never ever happen again
[Music]
[Applause]
I know the only reason I travel by train
is to travel with weapons false other
reasons include but are not limited to
meeting Donald Gleason and or Mary
Weaver for an affair play encrypted with
a random stranger or finding out what
baby tastes like also I know this
particular train car is so hard Edge
that they drink alcohol from Taps that
look like snakes but why is there a
knock dispenser at every table no one
who enters this car would come
unprepared to the point that this bar
freely hands out brass knuckles at each
individual table would they and yes this
is the Rick and Morty where the creators
decided nothing matters so it's our job
to say that everything does take that
logic who are you
dirty sanchez Rick is clearly firing
toward the ceiling and some of these
shots yet everyone hits its Mark did he
purchase a zorg zf1 from Gary Oldman
even in a simulation or whatever you
want to call this why not drink this
potion sooner
you can fart out of two buttholes this
is a true waste of real estate except
your weird leap and logic that has
everyone on a train going to kill one
guy I'm wondering who made the decision
to animate Jeremy from CinemaSins in
this way why would we take turns telling
stories about it like little girls at a
sleepover they are called slumber
parties and you sir are a meanie what is
with the Rick Sanchez Obsession I know
right and which Rick Sanchez are you
even talking about there's like a whole
Citadel of them this show plays so fast
and loose with its Ricks that I never
know which one is the real Rick and
which ones aren't it gets confusing you
don't see us just switching channel
narrators in the middle of a video
without ever explaining it I mean can
you imagine I know this story is BS but
how did that Christmas tree jump from
the right side of the window to all the
way over to the left side of the window
Morty and summer were hanging ornaments
on it when Rick walked in now they're
nowhere near it also good to see that
they've managed to set up only one glass
of wine on this table before bringing
out the turkey none of my business but
he didn't even save Christmas in that
story this whole episode would be
excellent at TV sins oh you don't have
to pretend you didn't date him we all
did now a lot of you will be focused on
Yoda in this shot but I'm more focused
on the fact that Rick dated Quinn
morgendorfer Total Recall Sofia Vergara
and Conan O'Brien also if you're an
octopus how do you pick which lake the
Garter goes on is it like a wedding ring
situation it's not a real train it's a
story device okay guys if you're gonna
do all our work for us what are we
supposed to even do show random pictures
of adorable cat costumes if we wanted
one-offs we'd do interdimensional cable
this episode is interdimensional cable
only this time Rick and Morty is the
show that they keep flipping to it's
like Rick and Morty an Inception just
had a threesome baby with devs it's Rick
and Morty entering their own portal like
Malkovich did in Being John Malkovich
that sounds like it should be a sin
removal so it won't be since nothing
makes sense in this episode I'm going to
remove a sin for the oversized tickets
Please arcade game with a huge monitor
that requires a seat a VR helmet and a
giant console to play ever
ruining your grandkids birthday this
could come in handy so in this literally
metaphorical literal metaphor Anthology
Story train air is continuity does that
even mean anything does anything mean
anything sorry to nitpixer
sorry to nitpick
doesn't that mean those two could be any
Rick and Morty has blown up continuity
as we know it but what I really want to
know is why are there tally marks on the
wall suggesting that someone was trapped
here for 10 days even in this Wacky
World it's hard to believe that Rick and
Morty can punch somebody just once and
they die instantly of course this thing
is just a circle the first image of this
episode is a regular ass looking train
in Space the track might be circular but
the train isn't there's probably a point
to this but I'm too lazy to look it up
we don't have to do anything Morty this
is just a structural guide we're
obviously going to impart our own style
I don't like how meta this is getting
rich you know I've watched this episode
five times and a lot of it feels like
the writers were going through a therapy
session like they're worried that their
original show might get stale it's like
a palette cleanser but after waiting for
this show to come back since 2017
waiting two years to get half of a
season and waiting another four months
for the next episode I'm not sure I
really needed an episode where the
writer is obsessed over their own
creation what's funny is that a year
from now this episode will be just
another episode in the pressure on it to
be great will be completely gone this
sounds like a it should be a sin so I'm
removing one shut up Morty you're 14.
you watch videos of people on YouTube
reacting to YouTube bet you really felt
that one Dave huh I'll be the judging
when we get too meta look I don't have a
problem with the meta I have a problem
with when the meta becomes a lazy excuse
just to do whatever you want and pretend
it's clever like when YouTube channels
get an easy laugh by accusing the show
they're dissecting of doing the very
thing that people accuse them of doing
oh wink a wink what's happening going
into a knack break you know it's kind of
like they're trying to steal our job and
break our will so hard that it never
returns like when parents find their
kids with cigarettes and force them to
smoke the whole pack bad news dad our
lungs were made for this I'm a bird
person and more sure that was a great
moment why is it that in this train car
that people get a stage to tell their
Rick and Morty stories also taping
photos on curtains we've been here a
really long time and nobody's taken our
tickets how does a guy suspended in
disbelief in space gather up enough
momentum to suddenly appear for a joke I
just answered my own question didn't I
Rick and Morty just made the most TV
sins proof episode ever with this thing
didn't they or should I say the most TV
since debunked episode ever
cutesy name news meet insert Joker sin
stop thinking and do it okay there was
this my name is Mike Johnson that's good
coffee wait is this how Morty is telling
the story or is this the representation
of the story Morty is telling I mean is
Morty Standing On Top of the train
saying my name is Mike Johnson that's
good coffee or is he talking about a guy
named Mike Johnson who likes coffee why
is lesbian part of her job title now
you're Progressive
I love you ever since you were mailed to
me by a doctor woman this is a brilliant
deconstruction of the bechdel test
mainly the idea that some people have
that following it inherently creates a
great narrative Jurassic world passed
the bicdell test fight them with your
heavy special time you do it too
wow you know what's really special about
summer and Beth's heavy special time
their pants stay completely intact that
new brand of Kotex is phenomenal I'm
that Supreme Court lady and you [__]
did it I don't know if this actually
passes the bechdel test Beth was called
Mom and Morty couldn't even remember
Ruth Bader ginsburg's name so I'm not
sure there are two or more named females
in this story
Rick save Morty by plugging his oxygen
into Morty's helmet but when Rick Falls
they are no longer connected and sure
Morty could hold his breath for a few
seconds but why do both of their helmets
now have hoses plugged into them don't
worry Morty nothing out there is Canon
as if it matters the show is to Canon
like the dursleys are to Harry Potter it
throws it under the stairs and only lets
it see the light of day when it
absolutely has to
if continuity doesn't matter then this
one ball that was definitely coming
towards Rick shouldn't be coming towards
Rick in the next shot it should be a
lizard at this point am I giving this
show a sin for not breaking continuity
yes I am who the [__] am I not real
nothing's real you can tell because not
only do these officers arrive five
seconds after Rick is stabbed they come
from two different directions did the
third one run in and then around the
camera and then in from the other side
well it's nice to see their cuts and
bruises from the rest of this fight have
healed up so nicely is this intentional
maybe does it matter lasagna I take all
the sins back if this ends with one of
these two bringing the other one back to
life and then exchanging a kiss that is
somehow both platonic and romantic Even
Rick and Morty can't help but play the
hits for a cheap thrill and if you don't
think it's a cheap thrill explain to me
again how the meeseeks play into this
scene in any way whatsoever I'll wait
time's up they don't thank you for
sending your only begotten
what are you doing you guys would never
do this okay I understand that this guy
represents the fans and or the network
but if Rick and Morty started praying
like this everybody would know it's
building to a joke which is exactly what
this does complete with a VeggieTales
reference I mean even if this happened
for real we laugh because it's so
anti-vim listening to Rick's voice is
funny enough that they could do a whole
episode in church with him playing a
pastor and it would be funny somehow I'm
thinking it would be funny somehow I beg
your pardon well it is Jesus and they're
in a machine so this is his deus ex
machina as it gets and I think that
deserves a sent off
so what do you think haha you thought
this was a big play on the setting of
snow piercer but it turns out it was a
big play on a scene from the 1991 Adams
Family
haha you thought this was a big play on
the setting of snow piercer which turned
out to be a big play on a scene from the
1991 Adams Family but it was actually a
big play on a scene from Ant-Man
nobody's out there shopping with this
holy way to get that in there at the
last minute we know how long it takes to
get one of these episodes done and to do
some timely last second thing like this
that's awesome but now that I think of
it why is this episode titled never
ricking Morty is that a play on the
never-ending story does that work on any
level is it a joke a play on words does
this episode have anything to do with
that movie does a horse get real sad and
die they should have just called it
throw logic from the train and been done
with it right now look it up it's real
it's not after the scene I immediately
grabbed the Facehugger I have in my
garage and went to the cave in my
backyard to see if one of its tentacles
could get hung up on a stalactite in
this manner I was really good at hitting
my head against the stalactite and even
after several rubs I was turned on by
the stalactite but I could not get the
Facehugger to wrap its tentacle around
it geez does Morty only have four top
teeth why have I not noticed this before
four last thing I remember I was ugh in
a cave looking at some wet egg and oh
that probably did it which makes you
wonder how Ricky even let this happen
based on how this episode progresses
he's clearly very aware of the alien
movies and facehuggers in general so he
should have been at the very very least
putting those lessons to use that nobody
from Prometheus learned about touching
strange substances out in the wild I
told you not to look at that egg it was
too wet
but to look at I've PornHub account
couldn't wait to take the leap from
things you shouldn't look at as a matter
of survival to shaming Morty for his
Porn profile could you not to mention
invading his privacy and that's your
grandson man you looked up his account
to see what turns him on also later we
find out that while Morty told Rick not
to look at the egg he was just as
enamored with the egg as Rick was this
might be a little harder than I thought
holy sh they've got an m m store oh have
I been watching one of those Rick and
Morty integrated ads this whole time I
thought this was the episode and this
after I wrote so many sins on that
Pringles ad last week I'm not putting
that back on my face relax it's dead
that's not exactly an incentive you feel
an egg in your stomach no
no glass half full yeah Frick is basing
all his information on alien then he
should know that Kane didn't feel the
egg in his stomach until it was way too
late so sounds like your glass might be
half full of glub glub Jesus Christ who
the [__] was I I guess Rick immediately
subscribed to his parasite's channel as
soon as he saw it or he took this phone
from one of the guards who clearly
didn't like Rick and therefore wouldn't
be a subscriber to his channel at least
sell out and sell vitamins or something
no Wendy's but close enough I did this
you and the amazing technology you both
brought us I get that the summer reveal
is a surprise for us later on in the
episode but there is no reason the face
hugging parasites wouldn't be mentioning
her here since she is the one most
responsible for the changes in their
society is there more nope nope I guess
uh that that's it just don't close our
Earth so are these creatures called
glorzo is glorzo what they call Morty or
is glorzo a verb because I'll be God
glores out if I can glorzo out with the
glorzo these facehuggers are glorzoing
about are they like the Smurfs why
haven't you blinked uh for 20 minutes
and why uh doesn't your mouth move when
you talk they're just now noticing this
these creatures clearly have gorzo for
brains geez you'd think Rick would have
better duct tape than this in that magic
lap Cody wears why are they keeping the
Facehugger masks if they're fleeing the
planet it's as if Rick knows they might
forget something and have to come back
later and use them again Rick's tiny
spaceship apparently can take flight
even with something like 20 times
heavier attached to it
congratulating yourself on not making a
911 joke which actually by definition is
still itself a 911 joke also I'm
wondering why during this entire Rampage
Rick hasn't been wearing his seatbelt
except this one time here just before
they see the not World Trade Center and
then when it comes back he's not wearing
it even though it's the same background
same framing same everything did they
animate multiple takes pretending that
the actor who plays Rick had to go to
the bathroom at some point and he forgot
to put his seatbelt back on so you did a
911. almost did a 911 we we went with
the Pearl Harbor we're pretty classy in
a moment of Michael Bay versus Charlie
Sheen I do think Rick and Morty made the
right choice but not sure it's a moment
to be proud of I've been getting into
beekeeping lately is something wrong
with that wrong with beekeeping no but
there is something wrong with how long
it's taking you to slice those pancakes
who even uses a knife on a pancake are
they steak pancakes I mean what the
glorzo I don't sequel It's called
Integrity then please explain
interdimensional cable too so Rick's
wristwatch thingy is saying that summer
is underground and that's it how
unhelpful is this locator thing does it
even have directions Empress is
everything all right
um sees them I don't get why Rick can't
put that shield around them again and
bring out some other weapon that he
probably has in that lab coat but shows
got to fill 22 minutes somehow I guess
[Music]
buddy I'm just gonna call this Deus
ex-harmacana because why the [__] does
either of them have a harmonica and it
just so happens to be the facehugger's
weakness
why the [__] did you tell your minions
to seize them you've been on enough Rick
and Morty Adventures to know that Rick
would have gotten you out of here
without having to come up with some
wacky plan to escape you're in a cape
summer how bad could it be no bad story
ends with a cape Justice League does or
was I simply getting close to carpool
with garcool consuming me Rick can we
listen to something else first off
people listen to anything surrounded by
other people who don't want to listen to
it without headphones I'm talking to you
dude at the airport on speakerphone and
woman watching YouTube with the volume
turned to 85 decibels you know who you
are second off why doesn't Morty have
his own device with headphones I'm just
saying they're currently in a spaceship
I'm assuming the technology exists it's
a toothpick I'm a toothpicker now get
used to it God are you desperate for a
thing this show is experiencing a
self-awareness crisis from the previous
episode that has spilled over into this
episode everything is being introduced
as a thing and someone has to comment on
it why couldn't the episode do something
where she simply needed the toothpick
because this toothpick is crucial to the
plot it's the only reason why
facehuggers can't grab her later it is
my thing just like yours is dying alone
[__] dying alone be a thing a thing
is something you do often dying alone is
something you do once maybe twice if
you're a Gemini how long have you been
hatched 30 seconds I've been alive seven
minutes uh I've been here for 29 minutes
I'm getting heavy me six vibes from
these things so all you do is live half
an hour eggs and die yes we
Stephen King presents Rick and Morty's
dream catcher okay you guys don't have
to listen to me but I vote you don't do
that and who's up for changing things
around here so wait all these other
facehuggers that have been around long
enough to know what their purpose in
life is just accept Summer's suggestion
with no questions asked and they're able
to get everyone in town on board with
that plan how the [__] do these things
suck the egg back into their bodies also
why do they do it they obviously don't
know who summer is so they don't know
why they should follow her also summer
seems to be without her toothpick all of
a sudden which I think is unwise
considering that's the reason she was
considered a God in the first place okay
there's at least a couple details in
this episode that I love the pencils and
gum stuck in the ceiling and the
Facehugger paper dolls in the classroom
honestly lastly summer I can't thank you
enough it's really weird that this
Society deifies summer but they don't
put images of her everywhere and give
all the glory to Steve Morty yeah I know
there are groups of fans out there who
have been dying for Rick and Morty to
make out it's probably the number one
requested thing on all the chat boards
but this is one of those things that
shows do where they play on that thing
that you really want and it doesn't
count it's like in The X-Files movie
when Mulder does CPR on Scully and the
filmmakers were able to tease that their
lips touch or when James Earl Jones's
voice comes out of Maggie and one of
those Simpsons Halloween specials anyway
I'm glad they got the burning will they
or won't they question out of the way in
season four now maybe they can bring in
Kirsty alley
[Music]
now that they're showing this part again
I've got to say this is the MC Escher of
animated X machinist how the [__] does
that tentacle get around the right side
of that stalactite when Morty walks to
the left of it it's not like the
tentacle is in a loop formation it's
tightly attached to his face and we
shall drive away from here and die
okay guess what everybody it's me the
whiny guy you never want to hear from
she's trying to escape with her family
my time to shine
this is what we get for evolving I'm
sorry we thought you were evil why would
you think that had a giant tower that
Blair glorzo is peace I know is there
something missing from this episode in
the first part of the episode that
causes the conflict the missile that
they were supposed to send to the Earth
was going to send a bunch of facehuggers
right their message may have been peace
but they were still going to send
parasites to a bunch of unwilling hosts
but before we get a chance to see what
it was going to do Rick throws it into a
building and it explodes this is the
most confusing part of the episode
because it's never spelled out what that
missile was going to do when it got to
the planet and it seems like Rick and
Morty were going to have to kill a lot
of these things to escape anyway so it
doesn't really matter if they were
peaceful or not so why is he apologizing
about killing them how is this guy still
alive hasn't the harmonica music reached
him yet I was working with a lot just
let me listen to the podcast next time
but the podcast had nothing to do with
why they ended up on this world can we
just relax and maybe watch some
interdimensional cable we don't need to
try so hard you know let's just take it
easy and riff you know I for one will be
very happy be when you guys leave the
Being John Malkovich stage and just go
ahead and make a [__] episode without
so much self-reference I mean I mean
it's kind of cute like you're
that
You parody Jerry's beekeeping makes him
attractive to teenage girls
this opening foreshadowing is fantastic
this rat gets lit up by some acid
leaving only his bones totally setting
up a classic Rick and Morty Adventure I
almost parked I know driving around in a
spaceship is cool and all but why does
Rick even need the spaceship anymore
since he regularly transports
[Applause]
foreign well I thought it was cool it
was also a great way to waste some time
so you could fill all 22 minutes of your
episode what is this face you're making
I mean it's pretty much the same face
Morty makes a hundred percent of the
time you tell him something it's a
combination of exhaustion and disdain
usually you ignore it but this episode
wants to set up a relationship Tiff so
now all of a sudden you're Mr Sensitive
shout out to the props guy on set who
loads the exact amount of bottles and
trash for Rick and Morty to kick out
every time they exit Herbie the spacebug
if this vehicle is such a mess why is
the only trash by the door
well I'm glad to see the hyrulean
economy has taken over the universe
there's no way Rick is dumb enough to
trade 10 red rupees for 10 green ones
the red ones are worth 10 times as much
how will you ever afford your
flamebreaker armor okay but does
anything beat fake crystals and a fake
arm maybe fake crystals a fake arm and
the wisdom to go ahead and keep shooting
until they're all dead also why are
Peter gory and Guilford Grimley even
holding guns if they aren't going to
shoot back these tubes have no regulator
to let the carbon monoxide be exhaled
and I don't see any bubbles coming from
their noses I'm no expert but this is
clearly a Suffocation machine
yeah sound does not travel through
Mountain Dew this well and to be honest
bones don't float in it either of course
Rick could have invented some sort of
liquid modifier to give it the density
of acid that also has some sort of
acoustic transmission molecule or
something but my patience for BS tank is
running low so since when do they title
these episodes in the open this is like
the Simpsons Bart gets hit by a car
title that comes out of nowhere
[Music]
I know this extremely hilarious
conversation happens so that Rick and
Morty will have to stay down here a
little bit longer but if the idea of
dropping their buddy in the same vat of
acid is potentially a problem then why
don't they just use one of the many
other Vats in the factory it's funny
they care so much but seriously this is
not a difficult decision
[Music]
look I've watched the John Wick movies
and those movies clearly prove that you
can't fire laser dissolvers through faux
acid water without at least first
priming the Xenon also there is no way
that Ladle was long enough to cover this
distance
[Music]
sometimes things are so funny they
actually need multiple sins removed
also I love this gangster character so
much I want to remove a sin but then
Rick and Morty end up murdering these
guys I really hope that when he said
even if you kill me you're a dead man
that means he'll respond in another
episode but until then he's dead forever
and that is a shame
oh
see now that wasn't that hard was it
maybe just do that the first time okay
also someone just give these guys their
own show I would watch a whole three
seasons of these gangsters followed by a
contract dispute that leads to a split
up fourth season just to watch more of
them I'm rescinding the fact that you
killed them but these guys are the best
what was it worse than when I was a
pickle oh that's right you weren't there
for that turns out kind of cool maybe
there's a connection there excuse me
that cool thing you did without me again
the awesome thing I I guess you wanted a
dragon I haven't seen this much fan
service callback humor since Jeremy's
College girlfriend narrated The
Prometheus School of not lap dancing 40
seconds of logos I guess the rest of the
family went on vacation does Rick
regularly Park his spaceship in the
garage there are times when this garage
has cars in it and other times there's
nothing but Rick in his lab so I'm
wondering where he keeps the spaceship
in those moments there's no such thing
as a bad idea Morty it's about execution
while this episode is mostly free from
the last two episodes psychological
self-evaluation there are still a couple
of moments in this episode that have
that hang up get over it already
place like in a video game but in real
life so you can try stuff and then go
back to your save point yes Morty I saw
it on Futurama and now the show is
having its South Park moment where it's
worried that it will do something that
another show did which became the basis
for The Simpsons already did it you even
dragged another Matt graning show into
it I may have never noticed this before
but does Rick keep a fire extinguisher
way up high on a shelf nearly Out Of
Reach all right class remember when
Morty went to school and had normal
interactions with daily life is it a bad
sign when you're having Nostalgia for
the first season of a show that's only
in season four asking for every show
ever also I don't doubt that this guy's
class is probably the worst math class
you could ever witness but I don't
understand why there is a two plus two
equation on the board unsolved nobody in
this class is having trouble with two
plus freaking two are they the show
attempts to establish here that as soon
as Morty dies he resets to his last save
point but that's not what we saw when
Rick killed him earlier and you may say
that's because Rick was the one who
pushed the button and I'll say well
doesn't that mean that it should only
reset if Rick died and you might say
it's still attached to Morty's DNA
somehow in the same person who sets it
has to reset it and then I'll say but
later Jerry resets a save point that
Morty started and you'll say it's just a
cartoon why do I care so much and I'll
say you're the one who started it man
and you'll say you're not Jeremy I don't
have to listen to you sorry I I may be
working some things out here my point is
the death reset thing is convenient and
unexplained can we carry on
trumping these examples of mundane ways
to Groundhog Day are hilarious but if
he's resetting when he misses why are
there scattered cheesy balls on the
table this turn into this long
relationship segment is exactly why I
will never give up on Rick and Morty
it's carefully constructed nuanced and
confident even though it remains
irreverent in crass sure you basically
know where it's going but it still
executes it beautifully take your sin
removal you Rascals you earned it having
said that it seems like Morty is so
Jessica obsessed that I don't understand
why he even takes an interest in this
girl he even knows he has Jessica on the
hook after he acted all aloof around her
a minute ago yes show we know how they
met we were watching remember this is
the show briefly going into self Park
there's is no way anybody knows where
the tail section of this plane is after
that crash much less created a detailed
map of the entire terrain if they did
they'd have already checked the tail of
the plane I guess the news didn't give a
[__] about the other survivors or the
other survivors died before the
helicopter could save them look I know
Jerry is dumb but I doubt he's I can't
recognize the difference between this
and the TV remote dumb also why is
Morty's bag on the side of the couch
open with the remote control sitting
neatly on top for this type of thing to
even happen so from the time just before
he met his new boo Morty never once set
a new save point like not even
accidentally dude went from resetting
cheese ball tosses to never resetting
anything cold turkey nope also I bet
you're kicking yourself for already
burning that Live Die Repeat episode
title huh I don't respect time travel if
Ant-Man and the WASP can do it I'm not
interested funny because just like
Ant-Man and in game you depended on a
completely random and convenient button
push to move your plot along you just
substituted falling on your butt for a
random rat and now you're the very thing
you despise also didn't you shrink
yourself in one episode also also Rick
has crazy pop culture knowledge for a
guy who's always going on adventures
drinking and building inventions
this goes by fast so let's sort this out
what Rick seems to be saying is that at
the exact moment Morty presses the save
button the remote looks for parallel
Dimensions happening in concurrent real
time that have the previous save point
moment just now happening the problem is
Morty was in a relationship for several
months which means that when Jerry reset
to that save point Morty traveled to a
universe where all the same things that
happened many months ago in his Universe
just started happening in the new
universe I thought it was impossible to
think of something more confusing
convenient and messy than time travel
but congratulations and even so this
means as many times as Morty pushed the
button and for all the seconds hours
days months that passed in those moments
have all actually passed in his original
Dimension without time travel which we
know Rick hates he's been missing from
his home family for quite some time will
the show ever deal with this no does it
matter garlic bread if there was already
a u in each probable Dimension so we had
to solve for that by melting the
previous Morty doesn't that leave a
dimension without a Morty shouldn't they
swap Dimensions how does killing one of
them even solve anything also it's not
like leaving a burning pile of Morty goo
in a dimension really changes anything
it's just a dead Morty instead of a live
one right that's right you little [__]
it's the prestige you prestige
[Laughter]
Prestige being used as a verb oh this is
a great episode the original split is
still time stamped I can make it so
those mortys never existed at all wait
what without time travel I can't tell if
the show knows it's talking out of its
butt or if it actually thinks this makes
sense and that's not a good sign you
live with the consequences those things
happen somewhere but you can merge the
probable reality so that only one Morty
did them how can you merge all these
realities when a Morty died in half of
them not to mention all the ones we're
doing one thing would have meant he
couldn't have done another thing wait so
so you're not even my Rick if this is a
parallel universe Rick that means there
are several other parallel universe
mortys who all challenged their risks to
build the same remote right there isn't
just one Morty who asked for this and
all the other parallel morties just went
to the room and set a challenging Rick
to make this thing let's face it there
are so many versions of Morty doing this
that it would be an impossible mess to
clean up and when did this Rick figure
out that this wasn't his Morty
so did the girl who became Morty's
girlfriend merge with all the other
versions of her who pepper sprayed him I
bet she's super confused about all this
right now
[Music]
reality of course not because Dimension
portals are this Show's get out of plot
jail free card also if that's the case
where and when did they enter this
reality according to my frustrated half
understanding of the concept it had to
be before he pushed the button the first
time right did he drag Morty to another
dimension while he was sleeping either
I'm not smart enough to comprehend these
complexities or this show is shoveling
so much nonsense on top of nonsense that
it hopes we don't notice or both both
could be true so Johnny Carson is still
alive and doing his show at 95 Ed
McMahon is 97 man Johnny Carson really
hated Jay Leno in this universe didn't
he our next guest uh gave us well
actually very little information uh
besides the fact that he is uh
impervious to acid so we put him on the
show without even rehearsing it because
that's how talk shows in this parallel
universe in 2020 were and that means no
sci-fi bull is that right Rick how the
[__] did they get Rick to come along on
this trip I feel like if four seasons of
Rick and Morty taught me anything it's
that Rick will be willing to turn
himself into a pickle if necessary to
get out of stuff like this why are you
building a Faraday Box to block out the
signal thank you Morty for telling us
all what a Faraday Box is I mean I know
what it is but you know not everyone did
but also Morty has seen Rick build all
sorts of crazy things how did he
instantly know that Rick was building a
Faraday Box and not let's say a deadly
Jack in the Box or a box to hold a bomb
or gorzo knows what else why go through
all the trouble of building a Faraday
Box if throwing the phone out the window
was an option and no I'm not saying fair
at a box over and over so I remember it
I super already knew that it was called
a Faraday Box you know what's really
bugging me about this scene the steering
wheel seems to be very low while yes
this gives us a great view of the car it
would be chafing Jerry's legs the entire
drive I love this contraption Rick has
stalled into the station wagon but is he
attached to the door the back seat
doesn't come with him so what's holding
Rick up during this transition I hope
you realize the tubing permit was not
refined relax Jerry we'll be in and out
in a minute all this talk of lube and
being in and out in a minute reminds me
of a what oh tubing right oh man they
got to Rick's baby mama fast I was
hoping they were going to do a twisted
take on the movie Lock sex with a living
planet fixed up for mankind stop
encouraging people to stick their
divining rods into Earth holes doesn't
anyone remember the 1999 penis burn
epidemic after American Pie and there
are Critters in those Planet holes come
on Gaia Baby Big Daddy Rick is here
what's the problem the problem here is a
perfectly missed opportunity to show the
animator's ability to draw anything
other than a gimbals we've seen Dick
after after hairy ball and when it comes
time to show the beauty that is the
vulva we get a [__] multi-tiered
crater with a sphincter in the middle
hitting me look at them they look just
like you they really really don't I mean
just because they have pointy hair
doesn't make them look like Rick the
father could be Lisa Simpson for all
they know guy a baby gonna need a little
raw iron and steam whatever you need
and then Rick summons a thing from the
station wagon and that's all it takes
apparently for Rick to build an entire
Factory out of this planet's womb
why go back there when you have the most
interesting mystery developing right in
front of you Jerry creates this murder
stick for no reason oh you think it's
for roasting marshmallows but nope he
whips a metal stabby tool out for that
why is this stick being whittled because
if you move the bar so low you might
actually seem like you're worth geez
they turned Jerry into this Show's Meg
Griffin didn't they they can Heap all
sorts of abuse on him without him
fighting back and is it funny you just
end up feeling sorry for the guy as dumb
and listless as he is I mean this kind
of lashing out would be reserved for a
jury who actually did Summer's friend
from the primordius episode
shouting on helpful directions at the
woman giving birth with directions that
are in fact simply stating what she was
already doing penis fruit also freaking
Beth were going through all the trouble
of helping these clay Ricks achieve
fulfillment why confuse them from the
start with what the number two really is
is it a watermelon a pear why can't it
just be a number also we have a pie
chart with an actual pie on it and we
have another screen that shows how you
definitely don't play Tic-Tac-Toe sure
just give the O's the game X's it's not
like anybody bet all their life savings
on yet another draw why is the sign for
interns plural when everything else is
singular this might be the worst sin
Rick and Morty has ever committed I can
add an online to the college work around
or just push them out through a pipe in
the back same thing uh I knew it
wouldn't be long before I had to remove
a sin I guess you don't want to learn
how to skip rocks either the first step
in skipping a rock is to choose a rock
that will Skip and not immediately sink
to the bottom of the water the second
step is to choose a body of water that
is still and lacks of current and yeah
maybe this is the joke but if Jerry
skips Stones by selecting tiny boulders
to Chuck it Rivers he wouldn't be
interested in teaching his kids because
he would constantly fail with this task
also Jerry survives this this series of
blocks contains zero cuberts okay where
did Jerry get a s'more he cooked one
earlier and gave it to Summer who threw
the once more into the fires of mountain
dysfunction a couple minutes ago does
Jerry just have spare s'mores in his bag
I grant that this is something that
Jerry would do but I'm sinning It Anyway
also now that we've sinned that Jerry
even should have one in the first place
let's discuss the fact that Jerry is the
sort of person who keeps an unprotected
s'more in his bag he is also the sort of
person who can pack the fragile s'more
in such a way that it doesn't crumble
even though he's survived a river
Factory and fall so really I don't know
if I should respect him fear Him or hate
him what is that this this is camping
that is a [__] s'more well I guess
that seals it I hate Jerry there you go
guys pump those cheeks cheeks
encouraging incest also I guess it's a
standards and practices thing but if
these two really aren't pumping cheeks
then the lack of motion means they're
doing it wrong if I die don't eat my ass
that'd be weird so your boobs and vagina
are okay then by the way it would be
awesome if summer was ribbing Morty here
for actually eating human flesh in the
last episode if summer is going to be
the teenage girl version of Rick this
would have been a perfect opportunity
for that callback but it doesn't even
seem this episode knows what happened in
the last episode
pipes you sure these kids are yours what
you've never heard me sing karaoke well
everyone on Earth at this point should
be familiar with the events of get
schwifty in which you had to show an
alien what you got and what you got
ain't that you guys self-reference a lot
when it comes to your writing anxieties
but character's not remembering things
like that is crazy to me
sorry sorry just trying to get the hang
of this thing who's he apologizing to
his family that would be dead right now
had the staff worked as he thought it
did oh sorry I didn't kill you in a
glorious fashion just then oopsie
[__] Jerry
dude for real just trying to smite me
Siri triangulate source of power did you
for real just use Siri to triangulate
this God's source of power geez our
Communications companies are going to
know everything now you see my true form
the clouds were simply a shake more
appealing to gaia's mind wait so why do
all of your kids look like the illusion
of you you look like Kid Rock Zeus does
anyone know who kid Rocky is anymore
mixing Zeus with Sophia hajipuntelli
would make more sense and probably be a
more interesting Google search honestly
also looks like somebody got some
Deadpool in my Rick and Morty all right
[__]
let's go this goes on for some time also
the power of a God versus a guy who has
gadgets and knowledge of a God and we're
about to see a fistfight way to DC
Comics show this ship has power also not
only does it have power they're able to
get the ship off the ground from this
position and with a bunch of roots and
Vines running through it
the thrusters but no matter whether it's
wings or thrusters this ship somehow
gets into space you like these plagues
I'm unleashing on your asses we never
once get to see one of Jerry's plagues
even if they're as lame as best says
they are I want to see the full brunt of
Jerry's plagues
makana X Deus show thinks that Jerry can
use his marshmallow roaster thing to
pull Beth out of the chasm and if four
seasons of this show has taught me
anything about Jerry show is
contradicting yourself about Jerry this
is another one of those weird animation
things the lava was so close to them
here that I don't know how they didn't
get melted by the lava before they climb
aboard the ship it's one of those things
where they're saved because the show
says they are and I refuse to accept
that see you put the fire stick to the
wood and voila campfire you have known
about this the whole time one of not
Rick's kids would be amazing at TV since
is that all you want to say to your
children before you leave oh yeah about
that title childrick of mort it's a
Children of Men parody title I get that
and I get the children part I just don't
get the mort part unless it's some
clever nod to all the death in the
episode but you know how much I hate it
acknowledging the French remember when
there were episode titles that didn't
need to fit the Rick or Morty in like
lawnmower dog they didn't call that lawn
Morty dog well I love this bit at the
end where Rick is scrolling through a
planet dating site I'm wondering what
planet would call themselves 2R Dash
f181 like they're content with the
random name some earth scientists gave
them oops there's a hole in my ozone I
didn't put it there did you I can't sell
it by myself I'm not smart enough
erogenous ozone Beth Smith Beth Beth
Beth Smith okay God it's just such a
plain I'm trying to come up with a
mnemonic device true facts before we
release last week's TVs video for
children of Moore we called Beth Pam on
a couple of occasions it's hilarious the
show thinks Janet's name is forgettable
too I am so sorry
um uh oh God why would space Beth shoot
him if she wanted him to tell your top
bugs the Defiance lives on why not just
write her name down on something if he
can't remember it congratulations to
your government business or Terror cell
on its acquisition of the nx-5 planet
remover by zamazakhs in partnership with
Wrangler jeans the product placement is
funny and all but how many aliens out
there would be ones that would wear
jeans and even if they would Wrangler
doesn't seem like the type to affiliate
themselves with Planet destroying
Weaponry that really feels more like a
Levi thing don't you ever Miss Earth I
don't have to miss it I'm technically
still there my dad made a perfect clone
of me to take my place man Beth brings
up the fact that she has a clone with
very little prompting the question was
don't you ever Miss Earth and the first
words out of her mouth are I don't have
to miss it which makes no sense but
she's able to do a perfect triple axle
from that into by the way I have a clone
I am actually disintegrating wow you're
dead is that really it we did it I
believe Jerry would be gullible enough
to think Rick disintegrated but none of
the rest of the family I don't even know
what this Gambit is supposed to do in a
post pickle Rick World other than to
provide the episode with a bee story
morning's making a big mess isn't he I'm
almost certain that the next time we get
a good look at this table we'll get
confirmation of oh it's like nothing
happened at all Rick probably did
something where messes clean themselves
up in some other dimension or something
Rick creates this grid barrier between
he and Beth but I'm wondering why this
thing doesn't go all the way to the
ceiling why would you create a grid with
this kind of glaring weakness okay have
fun pumpkins wait what does supposedly
clone Beth have in her neck that allows
her to imitate Rick perfectly she
doesn't even have a Tracker in there
anymore not that it matters is this how
perfect impressions are possible stick a
finger in your neck even if she had some
sort of device in her throat how does it
know to imitate Rick specifically okay
fine this guy uses military time on his
alarm clock but wasn't it just breakfast
like a minute ago we should still be in
the morning digits right also I will say
it's kind of interesting having the
typical invisible teenage male uses his
powers to be a creeper peeping Tom
switched around to an invisible woman
doing the same thing but a Peeping Tammy
would still be creeper-ish so I'm going
with this in regardless so I'll just see
you at cheerleader practice this will
only be the second time Morty has used
an invention to spy on girls in the
locker room in the last three episodes
I'm surprised we haven't seen a Morty
Rick Possible episode where Morty tries
to spy on the girls by going through the
air vents how do you like that [__] I
liked it more than my old belt you mean
your old belt that conveniently had a
similar blue circle on the Buckle just
like the invisibility belt did you mean
that belt holy crap what is happening in
this picture is this such a lurid
picture that the kid wearing a meth
Gator shirt is the least insane thing
about it I guess Rick and Morty have a
deal with Shoney's too that's the only
reason I can think of that would possess
someone to go there to get their drink
on I feel like this is both a joke and
product placement like if we weren't in
the middle of a pandemic we'd mock this
but secretly go there when no one is
looking my daughter having Space
Adventures this packet sitting by Rick
appears to be a pink Sweet and Low
knockoff and he's drinking a beer what's
that about
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're trying to take over the Galaxy
everybody in the Galaxy tries to take
over the Galaxy the trick is to be left
alone by whoever succeeds this coming
from a man who is destroyed no telling
how many universes and even recently
impregnated an entire [__] planet
that sounds like the exact opposite of
laying low oh look they somehow got
suny's TV into the shonies the eye was
broken off when Woody Allen threw a
baseball at it during a Ronan Pharaoh
report
I guess summer was just planning on fire
extinguishing the entire locker room to
find Morty but her convenient choice of
this spot is still convenient show gives
me irreversible irreversible flashbacks
if you can find Morty on a random
peeping trip why can't you find his mom
who's actually at the therapist's place
at an appointed time the only reason
these guys show up to ask Morty
questions is so that summer and Morty
can overtake the ship in ex machina Rick
out of a bad situation later
man for a season that is making fun of
sequels rehashes and callbacks they sure
are producing a lot of sequels rehashes
and callbacks I'm better than
Susan Sarandon self-appraisal after her
first day on the set of Speed Racer
somehow makes its way into this episode
and is that
froze the Beth clone why wasn't he able
to put her in something more permanent
so that this confrontation wouldn't
happen wow naive and attractive wow
jaded and hot Clone Wars but if you stop
fighting you both get McDonald's how
about I just blow my brains out starting
with hers okay Wendy's we love Wendy's I
think they even gave us some money the
show makes a joke about McDonald's just
so they can make a joke about their
Wendy's ads it's not enough that there's
a regular Wendy's commercial and a Rick
and Morty Wendy's commercial during the
broadcast but yet another mention in the
show itself they know if you're left
alone you're a non-threat what how does
that even make the least bit of sense
once again he has destroyed so many
universes and recently impregnated a
[__] planet it's not Citizen Kane but
why compete with whatever's going on
here you know I'm going with Star Wars
meet Starship Troopers meets my
stepmother as an alien what a crappy
Death Star does it really take this long
to blow up a planet the ghost of
Alderaan is pissed guess the Galaxy's
Most Wanted mammal needs her daddy to
come change her diaper come on kids we
have to go do a [__] piece of [__]
Star Wars which they dropped the ball on
the title of this episode Rick turn of
the Jerry okay but shouldn't it have
been a play on Attack of the Clones oh
I really want to know how these portals
work exactly because there was a
previous episode where Morty was stuck
with the gun and Rick wasn't in the same
universe and he couldn't figure out how
to get it to work which means it's not
something as simple as thinking about
where you want each portal to lead so if
there is some kind of coordinate code
that means Rick just opened up nine
portals to each of these spacebugs
positions by hitting a button on the gun
a couple of times and I'm calling glove
glove on that looks like summer went to
the Fast and Furious presents Hobson
Shaw School of using a dead or
unconscious body for facial recognition
as I watch Rick once again pull out a
whole bunch of gadgets to get into yet
another fight I wonder why he didn't use
any of this stuff when he fought that
Zeus guy from childrick of mort yeah
maybe he agreed on a no weapons fist
fight but Rick doesn't seem like the
kind of guy who cares about the rules of
combat some of Rick's extreme body mods
don't even make sense sure building a
panic room for your heart keeps the
heart itself from puncture but those
major entry and exit art of veins are
all still exposed and in the same
general area protecting the heart muscle
itself after a giant drill has breached
the entire chest cavity is so
ineffective that it's basically the pull
out method of interior Mech technology
how come some of the pants the nx5 can't
destroy Wrangler jeans these product
placement things are amusing and
tiresome at the same time their tires
amusing but what I really want to know
is how does one of the guys not know
about the nx5's inability to destroy
Wrangler jeans maybe we could do like a
Parent Trap thing together sometime as
long as you mean the Lindsay Lohan
version Haley Mills shaming
Rick survives this
never thought this was How I died
we're nowhere near Venice and you're not
a dwarf in a raincoat don't Rick now it
fascinates me that an entire family can
be this critical and suck this much I
don't even know where to go here um the
Kardashians the vanderpumps the
Chrisleys I feel like there's one
obvious one that could Trump all of
these but I'm at a loss let me give you
some of this sweet ass weekend at
Tammy's
oh come on Phoenix person has a super
obvious on off switch on his back why
everybody look at your little balls I
know Mom and Terry about your own kids
balls also please understand I am super
happy this scene does not contain Morty
balls but since I'm a sinner I've got to
sin that's what I do also also hugging
your son with his balls exposed
jerkoff's ready to get the answer to
your burning questions yeah like where
is the family car do they park it at the
end of the street now remember clone
Beth is just a cartoon remember clone
Beth is just a cartoon just where is
this secret room supposed to be in the
house this secret room would be going
directly into a visible part of the
house somewhere uh Goodbye old friend
just because you're done with the
invisibility Belt doesn't mean you have
to throw it away why would you throw
something so mind-bogglingly useful out
for Otto the garbage man to find it
but doesn't the tongue of the Belt have
to go into the buckle for it to work and
why would it make the entire truck
disappear wouldn't the Buckle only be
around a few items of trash and it would
make those disappear if this is the way
the belt works then everything summer
and Morty touched when they were wearing
it should have become invisible not to
mention Jerry's pee
tastes like paint and wood Morty would
you please accompany me to forbode jalon
Prime for death crystals you don't want
to sell me death sticks faster good idea
Maureen will get us through these
asteroids sooner the possibility of
successfully navigating an asteroid
field is approximately 3720 to what he
wants to give all of our martinis to a
family of immigrants I don't know how to
drink your whole generation you drink
for the wrong reasons
snotty and into jail science all that's
left for these Kirkland brand me six
boxes
Kenneth Kirkland what's with the strut
you think you own the school nope no
matter what
[Music]
stop
those were my husband's last words he
says tell her she's wearing this shirt
that I spilled the margarita on and the
earrings I gave her for Christmas I
guess I gotta learn how to live in the
moment a little more that's why you
always leave a note allow me to
introduce myself my name is cork I'm
kind of like the leader in here rule
number one in app development son never
follow the rule what you've just said is
one of the most insanely idiotic things
I have ever heard I created the events
Horizon to reach the Stars she's gone
much much farther than that
and I tell you like I tell all my boys
if you caught it anymore than it already
is you can say goodbye to repeat cost
time to be free
Adventures of Jerry and Morty huh put
her there at no point in your rambling
incoherent response were you even close
to anything that could be considered a
rational thought I started today
disgusted and embarrassed to be your son
and then later I thought we were gonna
die because you're a loser
no notes
ten thousand years will give you such a
freak in the neck you forgot the power
gloves today still wanted by the
government they survive as Soldiers of
Fortune if you have a problem if no one
else can help and if you can find them
maybe you can hire The A-Team respect
the
State your prime directive the draymonds
are not a subject for philosophical
debate they are a people your life as it
has been is over from this time forward
you will service us well let's hear
about this Heist movie this is your
basic mortgage Bond all right The
Originals were simple they were just
thousands of AAA mortgages bundled
together guaranteed by the US government
you were an indulge in volcanic fumes it
makes you behave like the village
drunkard in some early Irish novel we'll
reach the boundaries of Fantasia do you
know where they are I have no idea I
summoned the
come from the father's space through
wind and darkness I summon thee
monster stick that up your ass see
that's your problem Jason you were never
serious about the craft
power of 12 feet
and ever since that day I have hated
magic and all those who practice it
Shadow Jacker you haven't come out of
your masturbation cave and eons let me
show you how to break your three ways
it's a cat that is not a cat but what do
I know I wasn't born into the god
business I am God I'm dying Rick I think
I'm dying here man my father
can you recognize the sound of a man's
pants filling up with rain I find your
lack of faith disturbing
the Christmas [__]
of emotion
what the hell put that thing away now I
don't want to tell you again snakes time
travel I'm starving I couldn't hear you
over my own screaming we've talked about
this can you photoshop your life with
better decisions Jerry
[Music]
oh
oh that's funny you're gonna look
funnier sucking my with no teeth so why
did you date Rick Sanchez anything you'd
like to eat
Turkish delight why is there a dead man
in the sky if it's any consolation he
had very few loved ones maybe it
wouldn't matter
[Music]
and land with wings and hands yes you're
a bird and a person guess who's got two
penises and all the agency did you make
a penis dude release the Kraken glory to
glorzone totally welcome to Costco I
love you give a little yee-haw
they always do a little Yeehaw like a
cowboy yo oh that's a mouse come on
louder I don't sequel It's called
Integrity sequels suck by definition
alone they're inferior films ready to
form Voltron activate interlock no no no
this is like torture no I I I hate being
in my car I drive a Dodge Stratus what
is this face you're making well that's
my face sir you know who I am don't you
even know who my father is oh you are a
snob and a half and then Little Tommy
flip flams running down the hyperloop
his ass is on fire from Xenon fluid I
got a rash so bad on my ass I can't even
sit down you know me I can't complain
great story boss really detailed we're
all stories in the end
other [__] I'm a God you're God
I'm a God I'm not the god
of you in the next five seconds and
you're gonna swallow a lot of blood for
a [__] billfold but father I have
dreams and courage and the name of an
excellent cosmetic surgeon fear not
someday word will reach you about the
success of me Jennifer Love Hewitt the
gorillas just went wild they jumped all
over his body and threw him around like
a ragdoll to get to those blueberries
hey let me talk to him will you where do
you live for me you want me to read I'm
reading texts what's the difference
[Music]
first you take the gram you stick the
chocolate on the ground then you roast
the mall is Flaming you stick it on the
chocolate then you cover it with the
other ring then you scarf we're not
worthy we're not worthy
[Applause]
it's a house no houses
Elsa
your other hand honey I can't hold you
To Catch a Predator what the hell I'm
Chris Hansen I want my molecules back
sources tell us these aliens who call
themselves the new Galactic Federation
will blow up the planet and I for one
welcome our new insect overlords Jared
do you agree that the use of Puppets
makes you seem dumb and crazy I don't
think crazy is a responsible word to you
I said I want you you're not a clone
and who is that John cocktailstone why
would you make a clone of me just to
send the Clone into space stop saying
Hawaii in there father of the year
[Music]
hey over here look at me maybe you
should put some shorts on or something
if you want to keep fighting evil today
I like sitting next to you
makes me look so tough